also here tonight brit hume fox news
channel senior political analyst
uh brit this is an incredible moment i
think in a lot of different ways we've
seen
you know this story play out in
controversial ways
over the course of the past year and
particularly last summer in terms of all
the different
violence and rioting that we saw across
the country what are your thoughts on
joe biden's response to that today and
what you heard from him from the white
house
well i i think ben that a great many
americans if not a distinct majority
would
listen to what president biden said
saying that george floyd's death was an
example of systemic racism
and be dubious i don't think americans
mostly think our country is systemically
racist
i think most americans believe that it
once was systemically racist
particularly back in the days of slavery
but even beyond that
in the period it followed up until the
civil rights movement of the 1960s when
when blacks were clearly subjugated were
treated as
as less than full citizens were
discriminated against in a multitude of
ways
but the civil rights movement was one of
the great successes in american history
it awakened the conscience of a nation
to the injustices
that prevailed at the time and and huge
strides were made legislatively
and otherwise to overcome that indeed
you might ask the question ben
whether any nation on earth has ever
made more strenuous efforts
to overcome racial discrimination than
this nation has
and you know one of the great tragedies
in my view of this whole situation we
have here is that the
that perhaps the greatest achievement of
the civil rights movement is a nearly
unanimous consensus in america
against racism being called a racist and
and
being shown to be a racist is about it's
about the worst thing that can happen to
you
um but unfortunately that's been
weaponized now and the term is
the term is flung about with abandon um
by you know by politicians and and
and others and i don't i don't think we
are a racist country
anything like the way we once were once
before so i
i think this this situation we confront
now is
where you see politicians and others who
want want it to appear that everything
that's happened so far
is not enough and maybe it's not but
every step of course everything that's
done
to do better is merely a first step
because
i think the truth is that there is
advantage to be had
in waiving the banner of racism there's
a cheap one
there's a cheapening of all these terms
when you hear joe biden refer
to georgia election reforms as being
you know something that you know jim
crow jim eagle whatever
uh you know it it turns something that
is a legitimate
you know uh uh thing to criticize in our
history a terrible
time a terrible uh policy in terms of
its treatment of black americans
and you turn it into something that is
just bandied about as if you know
every insult every you know offensive
statement
every tick tock video from some 13 year
old girl
is the equivalent of racist regimes that
we had in our past
what can we do brit to have our
discourse actually elevated
on this topic as opposed to seeing it go
into the gutter over and over and over
again
well one thing i think we we need to do
ben is we need to speak out against this
loud and clear to say that america may
be
um for a mixed-race country the least
racist country on earth
that we have a proud history of doing
all we can to overcome
the legacy that racism left us from the
earliest days of the republican
republic we need to do that and we need
to not be cowed
or or backed down by being
by being accused of being a racist it's
flung about with abandoned we need to we
need to resist that
we need to denounce it we need not to
not to give into it
um and i i i watched with with enormous
regret
the way that you know major american
corporations which usually largely
stayed out of politics except for some
campaign contributions and lobbying for
things that their companies needed and
so forth
now getting on the train of attacking
that georgia election law which
which bears no resemblance whatsoever to
jim crow
and i see that with dismay i see the the
fact that critical race theory is being
taught in our schools
um the critical race theory is bunk
uh let's be clear about that it is
absolute bunk it's
it's it's racist i mean it is
just completely abhorrent and it's
un-american in a very deeply disturbing
way and yet
they are seeking to indoctrinate
children into it
i agree with that and i think we have to
resist that uh you know i was so
struck by that letter that the brearly
student the new york city student
uh the father of the new york city
student uh wrote about that school's
adoption of that
uh he wrote a very compelling message
against the indoctrination of students
with that stuff
and the reply that came from the school
administrators was so
weak and and name-calling and it was
just pathetic
this i think this stuff can be overcome
but people have to be willing to make
the fight
well the problem that as i see it britt
is
we are we are asking americans who
would normally just like to live their
lives to be good neighbors to be friends
to you know reach out across you know
all sorts of different lines
to be incredibly courageous
in a moment in which they're they're
being demanded of to to sort of answer
for everything
that their ethnicity involves and that
to me is just you know something that we
haven't seen historically in america and
puts
just normal average you know civically
minded americans in a position
that is extremely uncomfortable for them
where they're being treated as if
they're celebrities or politicians or
people with endorsements and the like
so how can they navigate this
environment given that
well the civil rights movement itself
been was a call to conscience
this likewise is a call to conscience in
a somewhat different way
that we are seeing the erosion of our
institutions the erosion of our
traditions
we're seeing you know as joe biden did
again tonight
you know our entire justice system
called into question
by the suggestion that the justice for
for people like george floyd and other
victims
is rare it is not rare it is common
injustice is what's in uncommon so we
need as a nation
to and as a people to respond to this i
can't believe
ben is as a matter of politics that
there won't be a huge
backlash against this cry that
we're a racist nation and a racist
people and
hearing that over and over again all the
time from all quarters
or from too many quarters isn't that
there won't be a backlash to that at
least in elections to come
we'll see but i think it's i suspect
it's coming
britt hume fox news uh senior political
analyst thank you so much for taking the
time to join me tonight
you bet ben